I was totally against the war in Iraq
from a.
You can look at esquire magazine from
[inaudible] you can look at before that,
and I was against the war in Iraq,
so you're moderating a forum with a
candidate for president of the United
States and you get hit with a couple of
statements that are presented as truth.
The crux of the answer is that he,
Donald Trump,
never supported the invasion of Iraq in
2003.
This part you can check pretty easily.
Trump's referring to this article in
which he doesn't so much explicitly
state his opposition to the war as say
what a mess it is and that he would
never have handled it that way.
Also,
trump's repeated claim is that he
opposed the war from the beginning,
which was a year before.
This article was published in August
2004 right at the moment,
by the way,
when public opinion was changing on the
war from positive to negative.
In fact,
esquire felt so strongly that trump had
misrepresented his position in the
piece,
particularly in this major foreign
policy speech.
From August.
I was an opponent of the Iraq war from
the beginning that they added an
editor's no correcting him at the top of
the article.
Being a well informed and prepared
moderator,
you would of course know all these
things that trump's opposition to the
war,
a cornerstone of his foreign policy
credentials is questionable at best,
and you would also know this,
which was set on the same stage to you
less than an hour before.
Now my opponent was for the war in Iraq.
He says he wasn't.
You can,
you can go back and look at the record.
He supported.
He told Howard stern he supported it.
Are you for invading Iraq?
Yeah,
I guess so.
So now's your chance to push back on a
statement that you know is a lie,
a lie about an issue that was decisive
in Hillary Clinton's defeat by Barack
Obama in 2008 ally.
This candidate used to separate himself
from his primary opponents.
Just a fucking why.
Correcting that sort of deceit is what a
journalist is trained to do for.
You could just move on.
People talk about you and commander in
chief and not just secretary Clinton,
but some of your Republican opponents in
the primary season.
Then they wonder about your temp.
We shouldn't be too harsh on Matt Lauer
alone.
Fact checking in the 2016 election has
proven to be a Gargantuan and uniquely
difficult task in the face of two
candidates with shaky relationships to
the truth.
I mean there are no shortage of clip
compilations on Youtube Showing Hillary
Clinton being less than honest.
Just a few weeks ago,
for example,
she said,
I'm the only candidate who ran an either
the democratic or the Republican primary
who said from the very beginning,
I will not raise taxes on the middle
class,
which
is kind of odd considering that 15 out
of 17 gop candidates for president
actually signed a written pledge
agreeing to no tax likes,
not just on the middle class on
everyone.
I found that live pretty easily with the
help of politifact.com,
one of the largest online fact checking
sites in the world,
and the Internet has been at the
forefront of dedicated fact checking
operation since the early 2000 in 2016.
The Duke reporters' lab found 96 active
checking projects in 37 different
countries and these organizations do
great work,
dubious political statements and judging
their accuracy on nuanced rating scales,
but there was one problem,
Mr Trump.
Let's stay on this issue of immigration.
You have been very critical of Mark
Zuckerberg of facebook who is wanting to
increase the number of these.
H One is not at all critical of him.
Where did I read this and come up with
this that you were to league?
I don't know.
Your people write this stuff.
The problem is that television is still
the number one source of information for
American voters and on television.
Politicians who lie often get a free
pass.
In the clip,
we just saw that moderator went on to
apologize for her mistake.
That's pretty unbelievable considering
that the article she mentioned with
trump's criticism of mark Zuckerberg not
only existed,
it existed on trump's home website,
that's unpreparedness to the extreme,
but it goes further than that because
even when you are aggressive and
prepared,
trump has a way of wriggling out of the
truth.
Like when he lied and said that he saw
Arabs cheering in Jersey City on nine
slash 11,
you know,
the police
say that didn't happen at all.
Those rumors have been on the Internet
for some time.
So did you meet Mr Yesterday?
I saw it.
Was that with your own eyes,
George,
we didn't have a people that were
cheering and the other side of New
Jersey where you have large Arab
populations,
they were cheering is the world trade
center came down.
We have three extremely important
presidential debates coming up.
Those moderators have a huge task taking
on candidates as shameless as trump and
as calculated as Clinton,
but their focus should be on the
audience and on what works and what
works on TV is imagery,
graphics.
I mean,
one of the most effective fat checks
this election season was by Fox News,
who not only called trump out on his
lies,
but projected the actual facts onto the
screen for the audience to see
your numbers don't add up.
The second thing networks should do is
fact check in real time on Chiron's,
as was pointed out to me by master fact
checkers,
Alexios [inaudible] lease over at the
poynter institute,
CNN experimented with fact checking
Chiron's earlier this election season.
Now,
it's unclear if it was a mistake,
but for God's sake,
it was awesome.
A huge problem with lies on TV news is
that they tend to be repeated or shown
without any clear indication that
they're false.
In fact,
I did that at the beginning of this
video in 2012.
The new America Foundation found that
the more familiar a claim becomes,
the more likely we are to think it's
true even after we've heard a
correction.
So instead of that completely stupid
audience reaction,
oh,
meter networks carrying the debates
could throw up a Kyron that refutes
patently false claims in real time.
TV networks,
by and large,
have steered clear of these measures,
perhaps out of some vague notion of
neutrality.
One debate moderator has already said
that he doesn't feel like it's his job
to be a truth squad.
What do you do if the they make
assertions that you know to be untrue?
That's not my job.
That's how I do not believe that it's my
job to be a truth squad.
What
are news,
if not truth squads free people the
world over still care about facts,
and we look to our news media to sort
through bullshit and lies to find them.
The fact is that neutrality doesn't mean
equivalency.
Hillary Clinton lies more than she
should,
and it's important for fact checkers to
call her and every other politician on
it.
You talk about leveling with the
American people.
Have you always told the truth?
I've always tried to always,
always.
Some people are going to call that
wiggle room,
but let's be honest,
Donald Trump exists in a totally
different category.
Lies and bullshit are his political
currency.
What do I know about it?
All I know is what's on the Internet.
You may not be able to get through to
Donald Trump,
but good journalism can get through to
the rest of us,
so if you get a chance to speak to any
of our leaders in a public forum,
make sure you're well prepared and
aggressive,
and if you understand what the facts
are,
let us know.
There is a new nerve read video every
Wednesday,
so if you go right there and click that,
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all the videos.
I really have to thank Alexios
[inaudible],
who is the director of the international
fact checking network at the poynter
institute who collaborated with me on
this project and whose work has been
invaluable and the research of it.
I'm going to put everything he's ever
written on this in the description
below.
It's all really great stuff.
You should definitely check it out.
I'm going to put his twitter handle
right below me too.
Thank you very much,
Alexios.
You're awesome.
Anyway,
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.